another debate club theo vaughn brandon
shop
coming to from uh northeast of scotland
rural scotland i've got a debate called
boys
uh scotland or ireland
scotland we've got uh glasgow haggis
william wallace lewis capaldi yeah
um whiskey is originally from scotland
believe it or not oh wow there you go
we've got celts we've got bagpipes we've
got lochness monster
um andrew schultz's mum is from glasgow
originally wow okay ireland
they've got dublin
leprechauns conor mcgregor
that's pretty much it andrew the fake
irishman santino he's not from
ireland he claims he is he's not his
last name santino i have nuclear
theo thank you so much for coming to
glasgow a few months ago almost a year
ago maybe
um no one ever no one else ever comes up
here so i pre
we all appreciate that so much um
[Music]
brandon schaab i know you're planning on
coming up here
i appreciate that as well gang gang buzz
buzz
keep the infinity in and yeah
[Laughter]
oh yeah man i love glasgow man i love
scotland man this is so
tough dude i've never been i've only
been to i'm gonna be biased i've only
been to dublin it's the greatest place
i've ever been
wow just because i've never been to
scotland
that's fair and this gives me an out
because since he chose ireland i can
choose scotland
win win all the way around yeah yeah
good submission mates
yeah good luck yeah we always loved you
chin what do you think about britain
when you guys hear about it
i always think sophistication smart
whenever i hear people talk with that
british accent
oh yeah yeah fancy jim went out there
with me chip it's been out there so i'm
i'm
also ireland by far one of the best
places on earth
you shouldn't try to get a neck hat yeah
that's how much i loved it i was going
to get a neck tattoo though damn
yeah would you all get tattooed
in ireland in dublin i'm not sure i
forgot the tattoo artist's name but it
was one of our channel got it chin tried
to get on his neck but homeboy wouldn't
do it yeah
still bummed about that damn he was
looking out for you
well i would be happy with it so
yeah yeah well cheers mate
cheers cheers man cheers cheers thank
you for the submissions have a great
time
good on you man
[Music]